continuamos con más información en
france 24 y hablamos ahora de economía y
estamos con daniela blandón periodista
nuestra redacción que nos va a contar lo
más importante hoy daniela en torno a
las mujeres en afganistán que es el tema
de la jornada en trans 24 manera cual la
participación de las mujeres en la
economía de su país estamos hablando
como ya lo dije afganistán pues liliana
que tal es mucho lo que ellas han
logrado durante los últimos 20 años pero
todavía queda mucho camino por recorrer
en términos económicos por lo menos han
ganado por ejemplo una participación
importante en las empresas el número de
firmas operadas por mujeres ha crecido
aunque sigue siendo una pequeña minoría
apenas el 5% de los propietarios por
otro lado el porcentaje de mujeres en la
administración pública aumentó del 18
por ciento en 2007 al 25% en 2019
también está el derecho de propiedad en
su momento los talibanes impidieron que
las mujeres tuvieran títulos
inmobiliarios pero hoy son dueños del 5
por ciento de la tierra
bueno van ir ahí la fuerza laboral
femenina en afganistán ha mejorado en
las últimas dos décadas pero todavía
falta más sí pues un pequeño record ehr
es cuando ocuparon el poder por última
vez entre 1996 y 2001 los talibanes
hicieron cumplir estrictamente su
interpretación ultra conservadora del
islam que incluía prohibir a las mujeres
ir a la escuela o trabajar después de
esa fecha la situación cambió de acuerdo
con datos del banco mundial en 1990 el
15 32 por ciento de los trabajadores en
ese país eran mujeres
desde eran mujeres y desde la década del
2000 pegó un salto y ya en 2019 esa
participación era de casi el 22%
afganistán está mejor que países como
india egipto irán o incluso yemen pero
todavía está muy debajo de los promedios
mundiales ahora con la retirada de las
fuerzas occidentales de afganistán
también surge la pregunta de qué
sucederá exactamente con los logros
obtenidos por las mujeres afganas
durante los últimos 20 años veamos más
detalles a continuación
un salón de belleza cerrado en kabul los
carteles hecho trizas simbolizan las
esperanzas destrozadas para afganistán y
no sólo las pérdidas de las ganancias de
los últimos 20 años también la
desaparición de la vida pública
las mujeres perdieron todo lo que tenían
lo que escuchamos hasta ahora es que las
mujeres tendrán sus derechos y podrán
trabajar pero solo son palabras estoy
segura de que la vida se volverá más
difícil y no más fácil vivir en
afganistán será muy difícil para las
mujeres
durante el anterior gobierno de los
talibanes desde 1996 hasta 2001 los
derechos de las mujeres fueron
violentados les prohibió ir al trabajo y
que las niñas mayores de 8 asistieran a
la escuela a partir de 2001 tras el
derrocamiento del grupo islamista por la
coalición occidental la participación de
las mujeres en la fuerza laboral se
disparó alcanzando casi el 22 por ciento
en la última década y ocuparon cada vez
más puestos en todos los ámbitos de la
vida sin embargo cuando los talibanes
tomaron kabul en una avanzada relámpago
el horror se apoderó por lo que podría
venir estoy después de hablar con ellos
en cualquier lugar del mundo y empezar a
negociar en nombre de todas las mujeres
afganas
pido a sus líderes que por favor se
sienten y hablen un informe de que los
talibanes buscaban activistas y a
cualquier persona que ayudó a la
coalición occidental la esperanza es que
ahora los nuevos dueños de afganistán
presenten un rostro menos brutal a su
pueblo lo que sí es cierto es que nadie
sabe que será el futuro de las 14
millones de mujeres de afganistán
pues daniela que se espera para las
mujeres en el futuro en términos
económicos en afganistán usted cuéntenos
es muy cierto liliana sin embargo pues
los talibanes dicen que respetarán el
estilo de vida actual o sea que las
mujeres pueden volver a de sus escuelas
oa sus empleos con la condición de que
se respeten los límites que establece el
islam pero dado su historial las
garantías de que esto pase han sido
recibidas con cierto escepticismo
de ellas ya pueden disfrutar las
periodistas están trabajando y pueden
hacer reportajes las periodistas están
regresando y hasta pueden criticar
incluso las otras ocupaciones las
maestras se están trabajando las médicas
se están trabajando las escuelas están
abiertas la gente no debe preocuparse
por nada daniela y entonces cuéntenos la
cifra el día frente a la muerte en
afganistán pues ha faltado una le tengo
dos la primera es que entre el 10 y el
20 por ciento ha aumentado el precio de
la harina el aceite y el arroz desde el
15 de agosto cuando los talibanes se
tomaron el poder allí el 47 por ciento
de la población vive en pobreza y la
segunda son los 275 mil
684 emprendedores afganas que han sido
beneficiadas por proyectos del banco
mundial que buscan permitir que las
mujeres de ese país creen su propio
negocio no todo es malo en línea bueno
gracias por esta información y ustedes
gracias continúen con más hembras 24
punto com
[Música]